now good evening and thanks for joining
us tonight at 6 30 i'm sasha loftis
honoring the lives that were lost on 9
11. tonight the professional
firefighters of nevada are hosting a
memorial procession in downtown las
vegas the annual tribute starts in about
30 minutes madison kimbrough joins us
downtown with the details
first responders will gather here on
maine and fremont to get in line to
gather before the start of the
procession at 7 p.m the professional
firefighters of nevada has led the
tribute procession in partnership with
the city of las vegas and downtown las
vegas for nine years now the memorial
procession will kick off with a march
led by first responders and military a
moment of silence followed by a toast
and coalition on third street in
collaboration with hogs and heifers bar
and downtown grand
we spoke to those on fremont street
today who can't believe it's been 21
years since the frightful day just a lot
of mental emotional stress for the whole
world
the history of it will never change the
time passes but it still seemed caring
the effect on us
and then it's like since 9 11 the
craziness in the world is just gets more
bizarre and more bizarre the
organization encourages locals and
tourists alike to watch the procession
and pay respects to those lost
it's unknown how long the procession
will last but again the procession will
start on main street and fremont and
conclude on 3rd street reporting in
downtown las vegas madison kimbrough 8
news now